[Music]
what angle do you think they're going to
take to go pack the court
well uh they've hinted at that
they'll appoint a blue ribbon commission
probably full of famous scholars and
distinguished politicians
all of them people who are ready to pack
the court and then they'll make some
argument about why the court is not
functioning properly
and they'll say that we can make it much
more efficient
and then this race thing which is just
dreadful you know because
the truth is the human soul is
immaterial
and if it is immaterial then the human
being can be free
and if it's not immaterial it can't be
free
and things that don't have matter don't
have color so
the idea that you would identify the
human being with the color
of the skin that is a specific evil that
was committed by the confederacy
and for that matter adolf hitler
[Music]
and he goes he said right so we're just
trying to verify uh that michael
shanahan issued the check that's all
well there's a real michael shanahan and
i'm thinking
oh my god well that's not good and i'm
like okay okay
so he leaves becky calls what's going on
they're trying to call michael shanahan
she's like get out of the bank
i'm like i can't this guy's got my [ __ ]
i leave the bank for sure they're
calling the cops i have to wait
hang up the phone a minute later my
phone rings i look at it i don't
recognize the number
i pick it up and i go hello and there's
a woman like
hi this is kimberly from suntrust bank
is this michael shanahan
i'm like yes it is and she goes
hi we have someone here at the bank
trying to cash a cashier's check
that was drawn on your your on your uh
from the title company
and i'm like okay and they said uh what
would you you know what was it
how much was the amount of price yeah
that was scott cogno was 30 about 29
thousand dollars even i think and she
says
that's right mr thank you very much mr
shannon said hey how did you get my
number because if you called information
you would have got his real number
and and i go how'd you get my number oh
we called the title company
they looked on the application that i
had filled out and i'd use the cell
number
and they said we just got it off there i
hope it's okay no problem no problem
okay thank you boom hang on the phone
five minutes later still the guy comes
out with some woman
counts out the money to me gives me the
money i stand up and he says
mr cogno i would like to um
say that i feel very uncomfortable about
this transaction
i said well what is it exactly and he
goes you know i can't put my finger on
it
and i said well it'll come to you
and i walk off listen
i was terrified [ __ ] terrified
[Music]
would you urge all the american people
not to take the vaccine would you become
part of the campaign
not to take the vaccine
oh no i'm not anti-vaccine
people call me any vaccine because the
way i'm marginalizing me and silencing
me insane
you know look alan i've been trying to
get mercury out of fish
for 37 years and nobody calls me any
fish
i support everyone 100 percent but what
would i do
let me just say television what would
you tell the american public
if the vaccine were available and if you
were invited say to speak
to members of the black community
members latino community
members of the general uh american
community
and they said
the vaccine yeah if they come out of the
vaccine
it does what okay says it's going to do
which is you give one shot you've got a
lifetime immunity
and there are vanishingly rare
serious injuries oh i don't mind you
know
jab sight redness pitching forget about
it i don't care
i'm talking about deaths or brain damage
one in a million
that may be acceptable in that case
and and it works and i'd say i'm
i tell people yeah i'm going to get it
let's go ahead and get it
[Music]
if you're saying 12 to 18 25 he's saying
12 to 18 months
and i agree with him and i think that's
extremely aggressive because of the
phases extremely aggressive
it is it has been 12 months yeah yes yes
but let's just say they can pull it off
because trump's going to put pressure on
him and they're going to do 12 months
okay fine
at what point are do you think best case
scenario
we'll have it ready that if we have a
million cases we can give a million
people vaccines
it could have been qualified you don't
give it to them when you they have the
you give it to them before they get sick
so it's like a fruit shop
so at some point so then that means you
have to give it to a hundred million
people it sounds like you've given it
two million
well let me let me let me uh let me put
a perspective on so some point in this
this development of phase one phase two
phase three there could be some point in
a phase through
three area where we're beginning to see
that
we're not seeing untoward side effects
or safety
issues and we're seeing some evidence
that's that's effective
there could be a point before it's
actually licensed if
everybody you know the scientific
community would come to a conclusion
that maybe
this vaccine can we can go ahead and
begin to use it before it gets fda
licensed
[Music]
you know china's doesn't have enough um
in terms of assets
but we d do need to deter china and one
other thing patrick
and that is that what china's leaders
did
is a crime against humanity if it isn't
then there is no such concept
there is no such thing so um i think
countries
need to hold xi jinping and other senior
chinese leaders responsible
and if we can ever get our hands on them
we need the 21st century version of the
nuremberg trials
and what does that look like what could
that look like that could look like what
we saw
with german leaders with japanese
leaders after the second world war
but no one of course wants to do this
but we've never seen a crime like this
in history
no country has ever attacked every other
country
and that's what china has done um it's
hard for us to grasp
the um the magnitude of what's occurred
but um unfortunately that's the
conclusion
that we have to face and
you know going forward for our children
forget ourselves
but for our children and for the rest of
the world um
we need to impose a cost on china so
that no regime
ever does this again
now i've heard a lot of different
versions of why uh
angelo got killed what what story do you
know why he got killed
he wanted to take over he wanted to be
the boss got it that's that's pretty
much it
that's it well that and by being the
boss
you're gonna have a ton of money coming
in he was shaking down
long john as soon as ange was killed he
grabbed long john who was
angelo bruno's big earner because he was
the drug dealer and told him how much he
wants and how i asked him how much you
make how much you got coming in and this
is how much i want
this is how much i want you just got to
give me what i want yeah that's it so
what's he making at the time before he
i tell you they were selling that p2p
from what we found out
and it came in 55 gallon drums and
contractors cement contractors would use
it by throwing in the concrete from what
i understand
they would make a half a million dollars
on the 55-gallon drums
they would get the drums for nothing of
course the contractors didn't know what
they were using it for by making
p2p with it and they were making a ton
of money half a million dollars per drum
yeah and how many drums were they moving
a ton of them i don't know
you're not talking like a lot of them so
you said when this happened you said
things got very ugly
what does that mean things got very ugly
well we didn't know who killed ange we
wanted to find out my uncle went to new
york
uh sat down with guys new york was
really upset like you know boss is
killed the commission like is saying
whoa what's going on here
who can get the okay for this my uncle
finally is trying to get everything
together
[Music]
drive the initiative of socialism
knowing that doesn't work what is the
motive behind that
it's got to be more than the professors
thinking the fact that the plumber's
making 500
000 without a degree it's got to be
bigger than that what's the motive
it operates on many levels that that's
just one level here's another level
you've got all these young people and
they are
uh they are actually living in the
middle of technological capitalism
but they're a little bit like the fish
that is not really conscious of the
water
because the water is all around them so
their world includes
uber and iphones uh and
airbnb and gps now none of this would
have come without technological
capitalism right
if you had left it up to the post office
for example they probably wouldn't even
have thought of overnight mail
it took outside age private companies
like ups and fedex
and then then the post office goes oh
wow you know even though the airplane's
been around for 100 years
you know we can still do that we can do
it now so they got
but no innovation comes out of
government per se there or very little
um but for a lot of young people they
take all this for granted they never
think about
how did they how did all these things
come to be they didn't magically fall
out of the sky
what is the system that produced them
they don't think about that
the consumer says is the meat good is it
healthy for my kids
is it gonna be cheap check i'm good to
go
why should i the consumer be so
concerned about what's going on
because there's a concentration so
there's an oligarchy of
power and control at the at the top of
the food at the top of the chain right
and that trickles down to you so they
are able to eliminate competition in the
united states
while bringing in cheaper lower quality
meat from other countries 18 other
countries
and they can put that on top of our meat
mix it in the grind or mix it in
uh you know you can go the grocery store
and you may have you may buy a cut of
beef that says product of the usa but
that does not mean
that it is a product of the usa so
basically what i
i'm telling you is as a consumer you
don't know what you're buying if i know
these bad times are coming i'm a regular
guy what do i what else do i do to
position myself better
well what a person does is what they can
do
and since the average person has no
financial education
they can't do much so like
you know i can short the market i'll
make more more money as a shorts coming
down
so i'm looking forward to it but the
average pensioner
they're handcuffed they can't get out if
they take the money out they're
penalized 30 percent
they screwed them they screwed everybody
that's wall street the government and
all these guys
so what can i do i'm one of them what do
i do there's a go back to employee
self-employed business owner
investor like go find a business go
start a business school reposition
yourself career-wise
you know is there a a one two three step
process and what i can do to be prepared
for it
well the next book i'm writing with a
guy named jim rickards he
wrote currency wars and all that the
next book i write is called the ravens
and jim and i see eye to eye you know
definition of intelligence
he says you should have gold and should
have silver
you should have museum quality artwork
i don't have any of that museum quality
artwork yeah
and real estate
[Music]
what typically happened to somebody that
was rebellious against a regime like
that
so like in school right
at school i didn't go to school i didn't
learn about the revolution or democracy
or none of that
things that i learned is like how brave
like what kind of miracles our dear
leader can do
and how bad the west the democracy the
the world was and you know everything
was brainwashing in school like even
like learning math
was like there are four american
ambassadors
you killed two of them then how many
american pastors
left to care as like five sixty years
old you say two american bastards
and the game that you play we don't play
with the barbie doors
we don't play some legos we play with
tanks you either use mud and build tanks
and say the teacher is like
why did you build this tank cause like i
will just think
because i want to kill our enemies and
be loyal to our dear leader